bassem quel est l'objectif d'alger avec
cette production locale de maxent russes
et chinois bonsoir et nori d'écouté
alger elle semble vouloir faire comme
ses voisins du maghreb à savoir le maroc
et puis et l'egypte fabriqués localement
son propre vaccin et ce en partenariat
avec des laboratoires pharmaceutiques
étrangers notamment russes et chinois
c'est le cas pour l'algérie les
pourparlers avaient commencé déjà depuis
des mois déjà avec la russie concernant
un protocole qui pourrait être établi
entre les deux pays objectif permettre à
l'algérie de fabriquer localement son
vaccin pour devenir indépendant niveau
du vaccin et pouvoir accélérer sa
campagne vaccinale qui a pris
malheureusement beaucoup de temps à
décoller j'ai deux vaccins seront dos
que produit localement en algérie à
savoir le vaccin un spoutnik russe et le
vaccin est sinovac chinois la différence
entre ces deux vaccins c'est qu'avec la
chine donc le partenariat qui a été
accompli avec la chine c'est que la
matière première viendra de pékin
concernant ce vaccin ainsi novak la
matière première viendra de pékin et la
fabrication se fera en algérie
concernant le vaccin spoutnik la matière
première sera produite localement en
algérie à partir de septembre prochain
c'est ce qu'a annoncé le ministre de
l'industrie pharmaceutique lors d'une
conférence de presse à alger
objectif vraiment pouvoir accélérer
cette campagne vaccinale tout ce qui est
préparatifs des cliniques sera bientôt
terminé et finissez ce qui a annoncé
également le ministre de l'industrie
pharmaceutique en algérie l'objectif
d'alger c'est vraiment d'atteindre 20
millions de personnes vaccinées sur une
population totale de 44 millions que
compte l'algérie ce le début du mondial
depuis le peuple et toute cette
fabrication sera faite par un géant de
l'industrie pharmaceutique en algérie le
groupe saïda qui misent sur 2,5 millions
de doses fabriquées par mois
le président de la république algérienne
ainsi que les autorités algériennes ont
déclaré qu'en développement localement
un vaccin l'algérie pouvoir économiser
45 % de ces frais car mon 45 % moins
cher de ce qu'ils dépensent actuellement
averts ans pour nice en bien sûr auprès
des pays étrangers et si la matière
première et fabriqués directement en
algérie pour l'ensemble des vaccins ce
soit les vaccins russes ou les vaccins
chinois alors là on atteindra 90% de
bénéfices et surtout d'économies face à
ce vaccin objectifs comme je voulais 10
pour les agéens c'est vraiment de
rattraper un petit peu l'egypte et le
maroc qui se sont déjà lancés sur la
fabrication locale du vaccin et en
termes de vaccination grenelle algérie
alger qui a promis un don le vaccin à
son voisin tunisien qui subit à la crise
duco vide de preuves de plein fouet
effectivement de rigaud et c'est ce qui
est paradoxal alger veut absolument
accélérer sa fabrication de vaccins pour
devenir dépendantes au niveau du vaccin
mais alger piétine un petit peu au
niveau de sa vaccination de vaccination
qui a pris beaucoup de retard il faut
savoir qu'à l'heure actuelle seulement
1,8 million de la population a déjà reçu
une première dose c'est environ 6% de la
population sur une population qui compte
44 millions d'algériens ce qui est très
faible le gouvernement a été bien sûr
pointé du doigt face à sa gestion de
l'épidémie du coronavirus faut savoir
que l'algérie a été fermée depuis d'un
an et demi ce qui avait créé beaucoup de
critiques de problèmes de tension
notamment que la diaspora algérienne
établie à l'étranger qu'ils pouvaient
pas rentrer en algérie
et puis cette campagne de vaccination a
du mal à accélérer l'algérie qui a
également promis une aide internationale
cpi voisins alors qu'elle même a du mal
encore à vacciner toute la population
l'algérie en ce moment ils connaissent
également pas comme la tunisie beaucoup
moins de la tunisie mais connaissent
quand même une recrudescence des cas là
positif on compte environ 800 un cas
positif par jour est notamment due aux
variants delta ce qui fait que le
gouvernement ait de plus en plus
critiqué dans sa gestion du courrier
virus le président tabouna déclaré lors
d'une allocution avait après avoir eu le
président karzaï le présent tunisien au
téléphone que l'algérie allait se
montrer solidaire auprès d'un voisin
d'un frère d'un pays frère
en envoyant à tunis plus de 250 mille
doses de vaccin pour aider la tunisie à
sortir de cette quatrième vague
meurtrière
ainsi que du matériel médical de
l'oxygène objectif damman venir en aide
à la tunisie qui traverse une période
assez compliquée assez sombre depuis le
début de cette épidémie si tu tournes à
des russes merci mais ça me chez b pour
toutes ces précisions complète en direct
de tunis sont tunisiens
[Musique]